all right so um let's get back to the um
filling your calendar with dates thing
like do you guys have any strategies
that you use with filling your calendar
because i mean like one of the things
that i used to do is i used to just like
triple book them in an afternoon it's
like okay i got a sunday afternoon off i
got a one o'clock a 2 30 and a four or
whatever something like that
yeah i stagger them so if i so the one i
like the one i like best like i'll try
to get earlier so i can spend the whole
day but if she flakes the one i like
best usually is the one's going to flake
most because she's probably a little
higher in smb so she flakes whatever
i'll do whatever else i had planned the
next girl comes through so that always
gives me the option to cancel on the
other one which girls all know the game
they do that to us all the time too like
50 of them will flake um and that's
that's a good flake rate for me usually
it was like 66 percent or 80 before so
you get flake rate down but
i stagger them um and then that way if i
get a really cool one or and a lot of
times where i live now they have to go
early because they all lift their
parents until they're married so i'm
like oh this is a late night check or
this is an early afternoon check or this
is a mid-day check and if they cancel
okay well i'll just put a creative work
block in there or
i'll get ahead on my sprint for the next
couple weeks
i'm talking workflows um yeah so just be
flexible with it and i schedule
tentative um knowing of three one will
come through sometimes they all come
through sometimes none come through and
just have other stuff
how many dates a week you know what you
normally booked jerry
ooh a week i go tentative like two or
three days out but that's because i'm
i'm in a place where it's like naturally
kind of a high flake culture already
aside from your marketplace yeah yeah so
so i feel like with latins like you find
the latins or higher flakers
well yeah they'll freaking have plans or
well their family comes first too so
they'll have like legitimate reasons
like oh my grandma's dog got hit by a
car in two states away so i have to
drive over there and like that's the
actual excuse that's what she was doing
so you have to account for you have to
account for cultural differences too um
so i found if there's certain times
during the day like 8 p.m i can i can
jump on there there's going to be
inbounds on bumble like hey what are you
doing tonight it says my profile what
what the experience is hey that sounds
great i would love to cuddle and smoke
weed and play guitar oh i sing great oh
do you play an oboe cool bring it over
like 8 p.m seems to be on a sunday night
especially seems to be off the
that so
in the moment or um
game works too um because no one's doing
it anymore yeah oh my gosh that's gonna
stay
okay so let's just keep moving around so
like your best steps to fill your
calendar with uh dates i don't know
where we're going so which way where he
wants to go next well one of the things
you can convey is that you're in need of
a date as most of you guys you know who
follow me on instagram i'm out of
cooking or i'm doing something in my
yard or i'm on my bike
so i'm not going to be running around oh
i need a date i need a date i'm just
like yeah yeah happens something comes
up whatever like it's again if you
convey a need you're toast
if you convey an even ask someone oh
their weekend was your toast
yeah i would say as far as scheduling
goes um usually it depends on right how
big the the pipeline is how aggressive
you want to get with it like the most
amount of girls ever seen at once was
three in in one day back to back to back
um and one was a total disaster one was
phenomenal and the other one was like
literally meeting like the
top tier like darth vader version of a
female where this girl
if she wanted to get a house or a jet or
whatever out of me she could have gotten
it it was her game was right on point
um but that's a whole other conversation
on top of the member's game right that's
why you have yeah face to face because
in real life is always different from
this right and i would also say
that where i'm not now with sheer
population density alone there's like 30
million people in this like cram metro
um i get two or three inbounds a day
without even touching the app um it
might not be what i want but it's
potentially hey what are you doing
tonight oh cool i see you're in town oh
like i'm gonna be over there later today
those are all invitations to initiate
conversation and move things forward
that's the sheer population density yeah
and i would say that um
qualifying like doing having a pretty a
you know aggressive qualification
process is key because like my flake
rate right now is about maybe
so like for every 10 girls that i
schedule for a date that i made off of a
nap or anything only one of them uh
winds up uh flaking on me so let's talk
about flaking too because like your
flake rate jaron was real high you know
compared to what i yeah remember mine's
closer to like renegades like maybe like
one in ten would flake on me and i'm
here in la which is like you know like
you want to talk about the places where
people are like like flaky part of
she gets back together with her
boyfriend or some like something
happens right like it happens
i i've started adding qualifying
questions too like uh like oh hey are
you are you free the entire night or is
it just gonna be a meet and greet type
thing and then if she says oh i don't
know how long but great well i'll do an
hour uh keep your night open if you
wanted to extend it if you can't keep it
open then let's do another night when
you're free so you start eliminating
those potential flake things like oh i'm
gonna try this guy out and if i like him
there's another guy and oh he's a maybe
plan you start kind of weeding them out
on the front end and then my flake rate
i think i mentioned the community a
couple weeks ago it was the point where
i was booking three a day and all of
them came through i'm like oh and that
that is a logistics nightmare you don't
want to do that
yeah ruins your whole day so i'd say for
those guys i was like all right now i
get to be more selective like now i just
literally get to choose well also say
some guys starting out you should just
you know stick to one a day and always
have like a backup plan where it's like
hey if this girl doesn't show up then
either you go with a friend or like for
me i gotta tell other side projects so
it's like all right let's go and show up
i'm gonna keep working on the side
project this night and then we'll see
what happens the next night so for guys
that are first starting you know one a
day is is plenty and it you know gives
you enough to think about that's a new
rule for me now and now it's like going
to be like two or three a week maybe
because it
you you don't want to put your whole day
around it but it does zap your energy
too and i like having creative ready to
go energy for guys in other communities
that tap into that stuff all right paula
so rich one one of your uh one of one of
your sorry go ahead
paul you were gonna say yeah yeah so i
was gonna say like so what
you know my flake rate was very very
very low after a point and i noticed a
difference between
day gaming and apps so abs tends to be a
lot faster so you're at making
connections faster having quicker
conversations having quicker closes what
that means is there's less emotional
buy-in for that meet-up there's less
investment for them so you're just going
to have more the general rule is the
less invested that they seem and the
less time you've had to build that
investment the more
chance you know chances that they're
going to flake so you'll that's an
increased flake rate so sticking to the
apps versus more or less approaches
you know you're just going to have more
flakes with the apps now i primarily
was somebody who would i would game
people on evening daytime whatever as i
went about my life because that may
allow me to be really selective
on who i wanted to hang out with and if
you have enough hot girls around you in
where you're at the population is good
enough you have enough selection and if
you're good at that then you can once
you make that connection with somebody
you can get some investment from that
initial
conversation i'm usually going what i
call two or three levels deep
immediately pretty quick in a
conversation and they're having some fun
and then
you know i do that close it might be
just a number social media clothes they
go to my social media it's high dhvs on
social media if it's number
the texting now back and forth is pretty
limited and usually i get less a lot
less liking like so that was the thing
being more selective with that so that's
just something to think about and when
you're talking as far as apps are
concerned i would actually intentionally
not close
because i had too many girls i was you
know had on my plate and so i would not
close
a lot more often i would just
i would look to that little conversation
here send a funny meme then i might get
in a little bit deep like tell me about
that or what made you choose that
thing or and it would get deeper than
just surface conversations
which would make them a little bit more
invested and then i'd go several days if
not weeks
maybe a week or so without talking to
them and so now that naturally
demonstrated higher value they know she
knows i'm dating i must be dating other
women which was the case and so now when
i go to close with her she's already had
a few conversations and she's already
interested and curious if she provided
she continued to talk with me right and
have those conversations and then my my
flake rate is a lot less you know once
again
one of the things that's really really
important to
minimize your flight rate is to only
deal with women that have genuine desire
and you like you'll know it okay like it
should be obvious that
um that that she digs your vibe uh i'm
like one of the obvious signs is that
she's gonna start to ask you some
questions
and not just like you know boring
like what do you do for a living like
she's gonna be like asking you questions
like hey that third picture is really
interesting where were you when you were
on that boat with those other two guys
that looked like a party sort of thing
right because she's interested in what
goes on in your life and that starts to
lower the flight rate too um irishman
you wanted to say something before paul
started
yeah um one of the
again
you know when you're when you're doing
performance measurement versus you know
your old mistakes that got you nothing
versus what we've learned in the
community and one rule that i've really
adhered to was something you mentioned
rich was like first date yeah let's go
and grab a coffee
and that just weeds out a whole ton of
crap because
if if a girl is really interested in you
she'll be like yeah sure we'll grab
coffee at such and such downtown and if
she's a flake if she wants you know
because a lot of times you'll hear
chicks say this in conversation oh yeah
i'll go on a date with them and they'll
pick you know some nice high-end
restaurant downtown where you'll end up
dropping 350 on a meal for two with a
whole ton of cocktails and then you'll
get a little green though
yeah and and you'll be and you'll get
ljbf at the end of the night but you're
you're 350 lighter so i that's something
i stuck hard and fast too which is great
and as i said like two of the main
things that i have learned in here is
stick to that and just inject your
personality into game as well
to build on that i'd say like talk to
everybody because a lot of times guys
get in this thing where it's like oh i
only need to talk to like a nine or a
ten like whatever if you're matching
with girls that are they're all fives
and you're just starting out like again
life is a contact sport the more people
you contact the better that you'll do
it's like i said back in last year when
i was guys that say that i only talked
to like nines or tens or never tens
themselves
yeah so i mean it's like what i said you
know
i don't know all women the same like i'm
flirty with every woman i talk to people
that come in yeah exactly because
otherwise
say hi
yeah just learn how to talk to women in
general so i kind of take the tape
i kind of take the tate approach when i
hear guys say nines and tens and i'm
like bro you ain't even see intense yeah
like you're in your life you're not
they're not randomly at the club they're
at some high-end club behind the vip bro
you ain't seeing tens
like
it did i just got back from vegas for a
week and i'm like you don't get a lot of
nines and tens on dating apps to begin
also they're not on they're not updating
chill out buddy yeah
the biggest people guys lie about is is
the smv the girls are seeing how many
girls are seeing and of course whether
or not they have frame
or not that's always fun guys
conversations
in any like kind of middle upper income
tier in any city anywhere in the world
and there's where your eights nines and
tens are at they're they're not out of
the clubs they're not do it rail and
blow until the sun comes up they're
they're at their gym where you where you
need to be at those hours
you